g'day everyone today we are exploring
more predators in the world of the
digital jungle unlike you my name is
lucas welcome to sum sub this year a
real digital revolution occurred a
revolution that you probably haven't
even noticed in january four and a half
billion people on earth use the internet
congratulations
but for the first time in 52 years of
the internet's existence most of the
traffic was generated not by humans but
by programs
according to barracuda networks bots
accounted for 64 of all transmitted data
and almost 40 of that traffic was
accounted for purely by malware what are
these creatures of the online jungle
should we feel threatened and how can
you protect yourself and your business
from a new threat
let's dive in
[Music]
let's figure out what exactly these
pesky bots are you see all a bot is is a
program that communicates with other
programs and services as if it were a
real person bots mimic our behavior for
example they send and search queries
through the same interfaces as we do
bots are literally pretending to be a
human i could not sleep
i was having human thoughts so i got up
and had a human cup of coffee
then i sat on the terrace sounds like
you're getting human all over what for
to simplify the life of their creators
of course the bot takes over the
execution of frequently repeated tasks
for example it can act as an online
consultant asking and answering simple
questions under the guise of an employee
bots automate routine tasks download
videos from youtube or tick tock monitor
the weather convert files and collect
information about instagram followers
you see
bots do not get tired do not get
distracted do not make mistakes or typos
therefore bots can actually cope with
simple tasks much more fast and
efficiently than us human mitsubis
you can also play poker with a bot or
instructed to play cards for you and
here we find a clear example between the
good and the bad bots
if you log into telegram and launch a
pokebot
there will be nothing illegal or
fraudulent about it
you will play cards against a program
just as if you installed the app on your
smartphone it's just that you don't
communicate with the program directly
but through the telegram chat interface
if you use a pokebot however to play
poker for you in an online casino
that is fraud and can cause you travel
from a simple account ban to even a
prison sentence but why using a bot will
give you an unfair advantage over other
players the bot is not gambling it is
mathematically and accurately analyzing
probabilities it remembers the entirety
of the history of cards dealt and can
play without interruptions for days and
days on end
against such a program a simple person
like me has zero chance of winning
that's why nobody will let you sit down
with a laptop at a las vegas cards table
bite my shiny metal ass it's much more
difficult to track the use of bots in
online casinos but it's not impossible
bots are revealed given their mannerisms
during games repeated bets speed of
decision making winning stable
percentages and total game time the same
analysis of behavior allowed barracuda
network specialists to determine the
real number of bots on the world wide
web
do you know what scares me about these
numbers it is the fact that there are
more bad bots than good bots the good
guys are losing would you like to know
more so sit back get a cup of tea and
allow me to go through the seven deadly
sins that bots do and how best to deal
with these
[Applause]
bots steal content imagine that you were
writing unique articles for a network
security website or a blog about
grandma's saucy recipes
one day you may find that there are
fewer and fewer readers on your website
this is a sign that someone is stealing
your articles
attackers use passing a process of
searching for texts and then copying
them these copies are automatically
published on aggregated websites that
display contextual advertising and
promote other sources if the google
search bot finds these texts on the
sites earlier than your text on your
sites the attacker will automatically be
considered the original author of the
text
of course the authorship can be disputed
but for this you need to discover the
theft as early as possible if you have
any suspicions that your texts are being
stolen check them for uniqueness it's
very simple copy a couple of sentences
from your most recent article to google
make sure you put your quotation marks
at the beginning and end of the query
this will allow you to find an exact
match of the phrases
if you do find your text on unfamiliar
sites simply fill out a dmca that's a
google digital millennial copyright act
form
link to that is in the description if
you often have to check your articles i
can also recommend using the copyscape
service
in the free version which is nice it
will show 10 sites that have copied your
text or photos just type in the address
of the original page
but if you are the owner of a small
information resource or a corporate blog
then i recommend using special services
for example try installing dmca
protection badges on your website this
will greatly simplify the protection of
your copyrights especially for sites
hosted on the servers of american
companies
unsolicited mailings comments with links
to other people's resources
any unwanted messages you receive in
your applications these are all spam
have you noticed a surge of these
recently on youtube i don't like spams
historically
this was the first malicious use of bots
back in the early 90s they were the
first bots to go through the pages of
the web and search for email addresses
this is an extremely simple task of
course all they needed to do was find
one word in which there was an at symbol
in the middle and a dot near the end to
protect themselves from these bots
you've maybe seen this on forums
some users would try to mask their
addresses for example using an unusual
combination of characters when typing
their email such as commas instead of
the at sign or dots in strange places
even replacing the dot symbol itself
with the literal word dot
of course such methods were also known
to the creators of bots so the tool for
collecting email addresses became even
more sophisticated
at first the addresses were shown in
pictures bots couldn't recognize the
pictures and people would actually have
to manually type in their own addresses
when sending an email from this picture
thankfully
complex scripts came to the rescue
they replaced letters with their numeric
codes or
mixed characters with cascading style
sheets so that people could understand
them but the bot programs could not
now in all popular content management
systems there are functions that mask
email addresses
whether websites actually use these or
not well that's up to the site owner and
their moral compass
therefore
i recommend that you never share your
main email address if you can
if you regularly need to share your
address for example on forums and
trading platforms get a separate email
box that you will not value and change
it regularly for registration on little
known and maybe shadier websites you can
even use single use mailboxes temp mail
plus or 10 minute mail will be handy for
this
these are extremely useful services for
instance if you want to connect to wi-fi
at the airport and not get a bunch of
ads for hotels and car rentals you can
use these temporary email addresses
now the sophistication is going to bump
up a notch a botnet is when a number of
devices computers servers or routers are
all running malware
most of the time nobody knows that
they're infected bots on the network
exchange information collect data and
even try to infect other devices meet
vent and surf
and if you see a resemblance to the
architect from the matrix
it's not a coincidence
the filmmakers were actually inspired by
his real image after all surf created
the tcp ip protocol an algorithm by
which all computers on the internet
communicate back in 2007 he announced at
least 600 million or a quarter of all
computers on the internet are connected
to botnets that means you
unfortunately the scale of the problem
has only grown since then
now in addition to computers hundreds of
millions of phones smartphone devices
are connected to this network too
and they become all too hospitable for
botnets in 2019 the mirage.net included
more than 500 000 internet of things
devices ip cameras presentation systems
even lg tvs and fridges
somebody from guinness i think we've got
a record here
such networks do not greatly interfere
with the owners of equipment but they
can cause some huge problems to the
entirety of the internet an example of
this
they are often used to attack internet
services at the command of the creator
devices that are part of such a network
simultaneously begin to flood the victim
with a huge number of web requests
the site of course cannot handle
processing such amounts of traffic and
it stops responding to any request
ordinary users like uri see just a
simple error message and nothing else
when we consider how much money can be
lost during a period of outage for
global internet services
we can begin to imagine the type of
damage these attacks can cause in the
case of online stores there is another
attack vector sophisticated bots imitate
real buyers add random products to the
cart place orders for people whose data
is found online or reserve all the
leftover products without making the
purchase
in any case the store owner incurs the
cost of working with fake orders and
real customers they're going to go
shopping on a less laggy and better
stocked competitor
it is relatively easy to protect your
computer from a botnet
firstly use the latest version of an
antivirus software do not run files from
unknown senders and for god's sake do
not download anything from suspicious
websites regularly changing all
passwords on network devices and
disconnecting from internet of things
can also help if you're the owner of the
site and you're afraid now that your
competitors who also watch our videos
will decide to attack you with a botnet
do not despair
you can simply use one of the cloud
services with ddos protection for
example cloudfare encapsula or mira
moreover bots have not yet managed to
cope with biometric identification
systems
the algorithm is too complex for them
they don't have faces so automated
identity verification can protect large
websites from fake buyers
[Music]
pride is the favorite sin of bots
as bots can fake website visits it
doesn't matter whether you need to
promote your website on google search
results add an extra thousand likes to
your instagram profile or even increase
your views on youtube all bots operate
according to the same algorithm they
pretend to be ordinary people and
imitate their behavior
fortunately
large services can afford to use digital
footprint technology to identify these
types of bots they just leave too many
unnecessary traces
by which they are easily calculated
taken into account and then taken out of
the advertising and monetary equations
[Music]
but there is also bad news
some services such as youtube have an
extremely negative attitude by attempts
from authors to promote their channel
with the help of these types of bots
instead of promoting your website and
channel and hitting that extra milestone
in your subscribers you can actually be
in danger of being blocked and banned
without the possibility of recovering
therefore botnets are sometimes even
used to eliminate competitor channels on
youtube it's simple just fill someone
else's channel with fake subscribers and
boom the creators will be removed from
youtube my advice to the content
creators out there is simple
constantly constantly monitor your
traffic on your channel if suddenly the
number of views skyrockets dramatically
with the gender age or country of
residence changing dramatically too do
not rejoice contact youtube support
immediately more than likely someone is
trying to expose you as an unscrupulous
cheater
that's me
[Music]
[Applause]
now in a video we did in the past about
how large companies monitor us
we spoke about how contextual
advertising algorithms work bill gross's
invention led to the emergence of an
even more tailored type of advertisement
one that's based on your search engine
queries
to make ads effective google and
facebook really collect and process huge
amounts of data
there is so much data that these
companies claim that automatic audience
selection algorithms allow advertisers
to then show ads only to those who may
really be interested in them this method
is then called programmatic advertising
it sounds so attractive this type of
advertising that in 2021 american
companies spent almost 90 percent of the
entire advertising budget just on these
strategies that means at least 88 of all
clicks on these ads were fake
at least that's what our colleagues from
oxford bio chronometrics claim in their
studies according to their data the
share of humans in traffic from
contextual advertising is about two
percent only in the case of google six
percent on facebook and linkedin can
boast 12
real people clicking on their ads or
impressive numbers it turns out that
more than 150 billion dollars were
drained into the void well
not quite botnets are not cheap toys and
advertising agencies content producers
and social networks themselves can
benefit from such frauds
of course to click a competitor's
advertising means that that company is
forced to flush their marketing budget
into the void this is just another
method in the bloody business of
advertising wars online
when i'm paid
i always see the job through
i think this topic also deserves a
detailed investigation let us know in
the comments down below whether you
would like to see a dedicated video on
this topic i only have one piece of
advice here
if you are conducting an advertising
campaign do it in several stages
don't rely on the golden shot spending
all your budget and praying you hit gold
in the algorithm break your budget into
smaller parts and manually test
different hypotheses
no matter how big the data or volume
from large companies are
in fact you know your customers much
better and in the end facebook's
interest targeting accuracy reaches 41
which is not bad at all compared to
programmatic ads
[Applause]
in the video about the mistakes of
famous hackers we talked about how
passwords to the secrets of real cyber
criminals are selected on the internet
bots often do the same thing they are
trying to gain access to your profile by
going through a pair of username and
passwords that have been leaked on other
websites
this is how most of those social media
accounts are hijacked therefore
first check yourself in the database of
have i been puned a classic name in my
opinion or you can check on breach alarm
here you can actually check your email
address and see if it has appeared in
any sort of stolen data
if you use the current version of google
chrome
and well you're not afraid of big
brother upstairs enable accounts
verification in the browser settings
chrome will then search for your email
and any stolen databases they have
access to for advanced and more curious
uses i can also recommend the dehashed
service it allows you to check
compromised phones ip addresses even
potentially compromised serial numbers
on machines of course though it's tricky
try to never use the same passwords for
different services i would generally
recommend creating several different
emails for different groups of services
as much as possible this way you're not
keeping all of your digital eggs in the
one basket it's funny
and finally bots can play a cruel cruel
joke without credibility
most often such bots live on dating
services they try to imitate the
behavior of living people
most often they pretend to be a young
girl or guy
but usually girl
who recently came from another country
they'll start messaging you saying
they're from another country which
allows them to justify any clumsy
phrases or mistakes in their answers
they ask more questions than they answer
themselves giving you the majority of
the opportunity to speak
the more you write about yourself the
more keywords the bot will collect and
the more accurately it will work against
you if you've been on the internet for
too long slightly gullible maybe you've
just gotten used to trusting people such
a bot will quickly move on to financial
issues it will begin begging for gifts
for money for that suddenly ill relative
they have even offering to invest in
extremely profitable business
opportunities i just recently came
across a bot that tempted me with a
quick profit from playing with binary
options i refused of course
as i only invest in meme stocks and
over-inflated nft coins
it's not difficult to recognize such
bots
ask difficult questions that require a
detailed answer if the bot appears to be
a real person from another country you
could even try using a couple phrases
from their native language google
translate can help you with this and the
bot is unable to use it themselves
of course of course never send money or
credit card photos to people you've
never met in person
they're almost 100 likely to be a
scammer
don't let the voice of the heart drown
out the arguments of reason you thought
i'd trust you
[Music]
as you can see technology is getting
more and more complicated every year
if in the early 90s bots were just
hunting for other people's addresses
which could then be easily deceived with
a couple extra characters today they've
turned into a serious threat to our
e-commerce and even to your personal
life
engineers and programmers are constantly
working on both sides of the barricade
but as in the rest of life the attacking
side has the benefit of creativity
criminals and scammers are always
playing with the white pieces
so your task is to take your digital
security seriously don't neglect the
simple rules of unique passwords always
doubt and don't believe everything
you're told don't be outraged when you
are forced to enter a capture again on a
website to prove that you're not a robot
or even made to pick out those traffic
lights from some random road in nevada
after all there are now more bots on the
internet than real people don't forget
we are responsible for the technologies
we create will bots become the good the
bad or the ugly
depends only on us i love you all
goodbye well that's it for today in this
brief dive into the unpredictable
digital jungle
we're here at some sub
see you in the next digital expedition
[Music]
[Music]
you